stepping onto socotra island is like  setting foot on an alien landscape this  place is one of the most isolated  landforms on earth located in the  Arabian Sea south of Yemen the islands  separated from the mainland of Africa  between six and seven million years ago  there are nearly 700 endemic species on  socotra that are found nowhere else on  the planet perhaps the most head-turning  of Socotra species is the dragon's blood  tree  these strange umbrella-shaped trees dot  the island it's top-heavy design is  actually an adaptation to Socotra zared  climate the large green crown provides  shade which reduces evaporation in a  place that sees very little rainfall  this otherworldly gem has experienced  threats to its ecology from human  development but the United Nations  stepped in in 2008 designating it a  UNESCO heritage site